este partido entre argentinos y
mexicanos había mucha expectativa es sin
duda alguna el partido más vibrante que
hemos tenido en esta copa mundo el
estadio ilusai que estaba mis espaldas
es el escenario de la final y hoy
demostró que está hecho para las
grandecitas cerca de 90.000 aficionados
el partido del mundial con más
aficionados en la historia desde la
final de 1994 estuvieron aquí esos
aficionados para ver esa victoria de
Argentina 2 a 0 contra mi contra México
Yo diría que la grada estuvo dividida a
partes iguales entre aficionados
argentinos y mexicanos sin duda alguna
así hinchadas de las hinchadas más
grandes que estamos viendo por aquí en
Qatar Lionel Messi y Enzo Fernández le
cambiaron la cara a esa selección
argentina que en la primera parte mostró
algunas de esas dudas que ya se vieron
en esa derrota inaugural contra Arabia
Saudita lejos del nivel de una selección
llamada hacer favorita al título fue
Messi quien abrió la lata con un tiro
que se sacó de la chistera desde fuera
del área y luego Enzo Fernández culminó
un grandísimo partido para con otro
golazo poner el 2 a 0 definitivo cinco
cambios entre 11 inicial tuvo el
combinado de Lionel escalón y antes del
minuto 70 ya el seleccionador argentino
había realizado los cinco cambios dando
algunas ideas de que todavía le cuesta
un poco encontrar la tecla a este equipo
argentino con México hubo una primera
parte bastante confiable pero este
equipo se fue diluyendo en los segundos
45 minutos Andrés Guardado fue
inicialista pero tuvo que abandonar el
campo por lesión para el segundo periodo
de lo poco que vimos de nuevo con el
trim fue Irving Lozano ahora a la
Selección Mexicana que se va a jugar la
vida contra Arabia Saudita necesita
ganar a los audios y esperar quienes ese
Duelo entre los polacos y los argentinos
haya un ganador y ojalá por